[Music]
meagan Markel and Prince Harry
say goodbye to Sussex royal the couple
made their final post to the account on
Monday thanking the community for their
support
inspiration and shared commitment to the
good in the world alongside it a lengthy
caption in which the couple addresses
the current cope at nineteen pandemic
writing in part as we all find the part
we are to play in this global shift and
changing of habits we are focusing this
new chapter to understand how we can
best contribute Harry and Megan went on
to say that even though they're done
posting to Sussex royal their work will
continue quote we look forward to
reconnecting with you soon you've been
great I hope that helps you understand
what did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
to take a step forward into what I hope
can be a more peaceful life Harry and
Megan's post comes one day before they
officially step down as senior Royals of
course part of their agreement with the
royal family was to stop using the name
Sussex royal for their website Instagram
and their uk-based charitable foundation
which was in its beginning stages
according to a source that foundation is
now a no-go instead Megan and Harry are
forming a new nonprofit and they've
hired Bill and Melinda Gates top staffer
Katherine st. Laurent to be the
executive director and their chief of
staff the couple has also hired us-based
agency sunshine sacks to handle their
media and communications so the palace
will no longer speak on their behalf
last week et reported that Megan Harry
and Archie had left Canada and moved to
sunny Los Angeles of course their
security has been a big talking point
since they announced their plans to
split time between the UK and North
America back in January but problem
solved a source tells ET that Harry and
Megan have already made privately funded
security arrangements their statement
comes after President Trump tweeted on
Sunday that the US will not pay for
their security protection the Sussex
says have been vocal in their political
and ideological disagreements with Trump
dating back to at least 2016 yes of
course Trump is divisive but as far as
the couple security goes it's unclear
whether the possibility of the u.s.
paying for it was ever discussed or if
this was an assumption made by Trump our
source says that Harry and Megan have no
plans to ask the US for security
[Music]